Oh, hey Charles!
>> Hi Michael!
How are you doing today?
>> I'm doing well, thank you.
How are you?
>> I'm doing just fine,
thank you so much for asking.
But I do have a question.
>> And what is that?
>> Why are we here?
>> Because we're teaching a class
on reinforcement learning.
>> But we've already taught
a class on reinforcement learning.
>> [SOUND] We taught a class on machine
learning, and there was a section of
that class on reinforcement learning,
so it was kind of a mini course.
>> Okay, but we've done this already,
so why would we be doing this again?
>> The idea was that when we were
doing the mini course last time,
there was all sorts of topics that
we didn't get to go into depth on.
And it's a topic that's
really interesting to us, so
we thought we could just kind of
expand it out and do a whole class.
>> Okay, that seems reasonable,
but you haven't convinced me yet
that this is really a whole class, and
that we're doing something different.
So what are we doing that's different?
>> So, well mostly we're just going to
be going more deeply into the theory and
practice of reinforcement learning.
>> Hm, okay well,
half of that sounds interesting.
>> Oh, good.
So on the theory side,
we're going to be studying things
like the convergence of algorithms.
How long it takes them to converge.
Whether you can put bounds on how many
mistakes it's going to make before it
converges.
Situations in which you
don't have convergence.
These are all sorts of really, you
don't want to hear so much about this.
>> Oh, were you talking?
I'm sorry.
What about the practice side?
>> All right, so on the practice side
we're going to be doing a lot more
in terms of implementations of
reinforcement learning algorithms.
And we're going to do, for each lesson,
some kind of exercise where you use
a system that we built called Burlap.
The sorts of topics we're going to
talk about include things like
temporal difference learning,
like the TD lambda algorithm.
>> Oh, I like TD lambda.
I actually did a thesis on that once.
>> Oh nice, okay good, so you should-
>> Yes, exactly once.
>> Okay, [LAUGH] so you should be
interested in hearing about that or
maybe even talking about that.
We're also going to be talking about
how you can express things using
reward functions.
Which is a really important topic
in reinforcement learning because
all of the way that we communicate
with the algorithms is in terms of
their incentives in the form of rewards.
>> I like that,
that makes a lot of sense.
So that's sort of the practical
things that matter about making
reinforcement learning actually
work in the, wow, let's do that.
I like that.
What else?
>> We should be talking
about generalization and
scaling to some degree.
>> Oh, I like that.
I want to talk about generalization and
scaling, and
I want to tie it back in to abstraction.
>> Oh, that's a really important topic,
great.
>> Okay, cool.
Can I do that?
>> Sure, why don't you do that piece.
And I'll talk about partially
observable Markov decision processes,
which is decision-making when you
don't have complete knowledge about
the current state of the environment.
>> Okay, that's seems reasonable.
I'll trade you.
You can do POMDPs,
if you let me do options.
>> Okay, all right.
>> And, Monte Carlo methods.
>> Okay, it's a deal.
But we're also going to talk about
game theory which is awesome,
because it has theory
right there in the name.
>> Okay that's true, but it also has
game right there in the name, and
that's what makes it cool.
>> It should be fun for everyone.
>> Yes, fun for the whole family.
>> So, in the game theory section, we're
actually going to hearken back to things
that we did in the previous mini course.
But then we're going to update
it by giving more details about
different solution concepts.
>> Oh right, that's right, last time we
did this class we talked about all these
things besides Nash equilibria
that were really interesting.
And so we're going to have
a chance to talk about that now?
>> Yep.
>> Good, so
can we do correlated equilibrium?
>> You can do correlated equilibrium.
>> I'll do correlated equilibrium,
sounds good.
>> All right, so are you ready to go?
>> I think I'm ready to go, so let's go.